I want to do one other thing with you
guys because I like this phrase cultural
recklessness speaking of cultural
recklessness someone at a network once
gave Stephen Colbert a job to host a
late night show here is Stephen Colbert
talking about Joe Biden finally lifting
the covid regulations well eventually
lifting them see tonight breathing easy
because the White House has finally
announced they plan to end the covet
Public Health Emergency in may take that
covid we beat you shove that up your
nose and rotate it five times
this is this has been a long time coming
I wish you could see the smiles on the
faces of my audience and I wish I could
too because they're still wearing masks
the end is near
the end is near this is a huge moment
after all the covid we've all been
through the Delta variant uh Omicron
Omicron ba2 xbb 0.1.5
uh z95
God irony is dead comedy is dead I mean
the fact that those people are still
wearing masks and they're applauding it
and he's making a joke about them while
he's not masked just it's the perfect
snapshot of what kovid became but
Jeffrey you know what I'm going to do
here because every time you're on I give
you credit you from day one of covid
wrote a piece I mean literally day one
of covet if not before it really hit
saying that none of this was going to
work lockdowns masks the whole freaking
thing so credit where credit is due so I
hand it to you yeah that was January
27th I wrote that and uh I wrote it
again on March 8th I wrote it again on
March 12th and I watched everything but
the watch the whole world go dark and
the three uh
how would you say hammer blows to
American Liberty in the form of
lockdowns and then and then the mask
mandates and we know now of course we
knew then that the mask don't do
anything to stop spread of a virus and
then finally the vaccine mandates the
three tests of your compliance and your
intelligence unfortunately a lot of
people failed all three a lot of people
failed at least one of those three but
uh the the really why is an intelligent
among us and you're among them uh you
know passed all three tests so but it's
interesting that he's still got his
audience mask it occurred to me watching
that when I first I first saw that clip
I thought wow these people just continue
to engage in these mythological
superstitious religions what's wrong
with it but then he realized something
this is a way that he can assure that
everybody in his audience is going to
laugh at his jokes there's anybody who
would sit there in a mass
this kind of got to be an idiot right so
it's self-select filtering the
population of his audience to make sure
that people think he's funny
I mean vivec isn't it just extraordinary
watching that at this point and that
people still I mean it goes to the group
think it goes to the the failure of of
just all of us I would put all of us
myself included that we all should have
screamed more I was pretty good after
two weeks to flatten the curve I pretty
much saw it right then as I said Jeffrey
got it on day one but that we all should
have been just absolutely enraged and I
think what what scares me now is that
there's a whole bunch of people that are
going to gladly welcome it when it comes
for climate lockdowns or coven six or or
monkey pox or whatever's next or climate
change right climate catastrophe because
that is definitely the one that is
coming with the same religion rearing
his head under under new Avatar if you'd
like more sane takes on our insane World
check out our direct message clips
playlist and if you want to watch more
full episodes of our live round tables
watch our round tables playlist they're
both right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Nation Bell